a person's height has not been in
question this much since I posted the
picture of me and my good buddy Mark
Ellis meeting for Tom Cruise Jack
Reacher is a new film directed and
written by Christopher McQuarrie it
stars Tom Cruise Rosamund Pike Richard
Jenkins and some other very talented
people as well this film is adapted from
the novel one-shot by Lee Child from the
series of books based off of the Jack
Reacher character it's about an
ex-military police officer somebody who
investigated crimes in the military sort
of like a few good men interesting this
guy can do everything he's kind of like
Liam Neeson's character in taken his
combat skills gunplay skills knife
skills run fast skills calm and Tom
Cruise plays Jack Reacher and in this
film he is investigating along with
Rosamund Pike a lawyer a crime that
happened in which a sniper killed a lot
of innocent people the suspect that they
believe is the killer asks for Jack
Reacher specifically to investigate this
crime this of course catches Reacher's
attention and we have a film now I was
interested in it because it looked very
interesting and I am a fan of Tom Cruise
I find that he's a very dedicated actor
but I know that a lot of the fans were
upset because the character of Jack
Reacher and the novel's is six-foot-five
he's like 230 240 pounds he has this
huge broad chest and Tom Cruise is 5 7 I
understand that fans are very worried
about that and they're afraid that their
beloved source material is going to be
ruined in some way and I get that I
understand that and I've sold the
trailers for this movie and it looked
like a fun entertaining action film and
I went to the movie just hoping that it
would be a good action film it's not it
is a great mystery this film is not your
standard action film as these trailers
want you to think as Mission Impossible
5 this is a very suspenseful mystery
film and I was very engrossed by this
movie from beginning to end it does have
a lot of bursts of action and a
satisfying amount of action scenes where
your standard audience that just wanted
to see a good action movie will still be
satisfied but this is a film that many
people will go into expecting it to be a
certain way it's not this is a
disturbing violent and
very scary film that actually has a real
sense of some fright and some realism to
a lot of the events that I've portrayed
particularly in the opening scene which
was breathtaking I was on the edge of my
seat I was just like gripping I it was
so intense this opening scene and it was
so well directed in fact that's probably
the most impressive aspect of this film
is the direction it's extremely well
done there's a lot of scenes that could
have been done in a very standard way
that were extremely fluidly directed and
I was just so surprised at the level of
talent that was on display behind the
camera in this movie and it makes sense
to me now that they immediately signed
Christopher McQuarrie the director and
writer of this film from Mission
Impossible 5 after seeing Jack Reacher
I'm excited for that now because this
guy is talented now as for the character
of Jack Reacher I did a lot of research
about him I didn't want to spoil too
much of myself for the movie but I
wanted to look into the books and the
novels and I got to say from what I've
learned and from what I've read from the
books I think Tom Cruise nails it and
I'm not just saying that because I'm a
fan of him and you guys know that I'm a
fan of him and I know that there are
people who are just ready to go you like
anything with Tom Cruise it's not true I
put in Lions for lambs with Tom Cruise
and Robert Redford I literally turned it
off like 20 minutes in it was so bad if
I think Tom Cruise is bad in the movie
I'm gonna say it I think he's excellent
in this role for a lot of different
reasons
he is stoic he's cold he's quiet he's
not like the Tom Cruise you've seen in
previous movies where you feel like he's
trying to maintain this very good guy
ish public image this character in this
movie if he doesn't like you he's gonna
kill you there's a scene this movie that
I will not spoil on a payphone where he
says this line to this guy and I was
like holy crap that was awesome I got
goosebumps it was so well delivered some
very good performances from Robert
Duvall Richard Jenkins Rosamund Pike in
general as well this film is a very
engrossing mystery suspense detective
crime thriller with a lot of evidence
sifting and lots of talk and lots of
dialogue very well-done dialogue I felt
yes you feel that it's a movie and you
understand that you're watching a movie
and these are characters and they're
they're very intense and Stern they're
in a movie but for what this movie is
trying to be which is an intense
crime thriller I think it succeeds
marvelously and although the film is
very suspenseful with a very low deep
score that really evokes this feeling of
suspense the film has some really
impressive action sequences namely
possibly my favorite car chase of the
year one of the reasons this chase I
thought was so good besides the way the
film was directed was Tom Cruise in
general because as you guys know the man
is insane he does his own stunts and
he's gonna kill himself one day I mean
and Mission Possible for that scene on
the Burj Khalifa the building that's one
of the most suspenseful like
white-knuckle sweaty palm scenes I've
ever seen because he did his own stunts
in this film there are scenes where the
car is just spinning and spinning and it
slams into walls and cars and then you
can see that it's Tom Cruise behind the
wheel and if there's no trick
photography there you can tell wow he
really did that himself there's a ton of
stuff like that throughout this whole
scene you can't even get this sense of a
stunt driver and I was so blown away by
that and impressed because what an actor
cares that much about the audience and
respects the audience that much to show
the hero himself or whoever this
character is doing the stuff that his
character is doing I'm gonna respect him
right back as an actor he's at the top
of his game here and he's so good in
this film with the physical scenes the
fight scenes everything was very well
done the film looks terrific it's acted
very well it's an engrossing mystery
with a creepy villain this guy is
apparently going to be John McClane son
in die hard 5 interested in seeing how
that goes
the film also has a very good sense of
humor that I was surprised by and that's
something that I wasn't expecting and I
was glad to see it there I do have a big
issue with the film and it's kind of a
big problem and it's what bump the movie
down a grade for me it has an ending
which I will not spoil of course but if
you guys saw Prometheus I know a lot of
people had a problem with that movie
that it ended in a way that seemed like
it needed a sequel to explain a lot of
the things that happened in that movie
and a lot of people didn't like that I
understand that and this movie has a
similar problem because the way the film
ended was very satisfying to me but I
felt like some of the plot points
weren't entirely finished yet and I
would have liked to have seen more
resolution with certain things and a few
more explanations
I feel like perhaps I may have missed
something due to the fact that this film
is so carefully crafted I can tell it's
written and directed by the
named guy and he had a lot of love for
this film and so perhaps I missed
something but I feel like there are
definitely sequels that can be spawned
from this movie particularly because of
how many books there are in the series
overall I was extremely impressed with
the film's look Beall tone and acting
and some of the great stunt work in that
car chase scene and in the fight scenes
in general I really enjoy Jack Reacher I
am very happy to say that it's a lot of
fun go in this movie and just have fun
it's an entertaining film it is however
a little disturbing at times
nevertheless I really enjoy Jack Reacher
and I'm gonna give it an A - thanks a
lot for watching guys and as always if
you liked this review then you can click
right here and get stuck menage
[Music]